الليلة أيضًا ، هناك ارتباك
وغموض حول مكان وجود
المنشق
الروسي أليكسيان نافالني فلاديمير بوتين ، حاول
المحامون الأكثر صراحةً من نافالني
زيارته اليوم في المستعمرة العقابية
حيث كان يقضي
عقوبته وقيل لهم إنه لم يعد
موجودًا
الآن  نقل navalny سيكون متماشيا مع
أمر القاضي في وقت سابق من هذا العام
لفترة سجن إضافية قال أحد محامي البحرية لشبكة CNN
إنهم يعتقدون
أنه نُقل إلى سجن حراسة مشددة
لكنهم لا يعرفون على وجه اليقين
أي سجن لم يؤكده أحد على
وجهة واحدة محتملة.  ذكرت
وسائل الإعلام الروسية الحكومية التي انضمت إلينا ماريا
بيبسيك التي تساعد في إدارة مؤسسة نافالني
لمكافحة الفساد أثناء وجوده في
السجن ، وهي أيضًا المنتج
التنفيذي لفيلم سي إن إن نافالني الآن على قناة سي إن إن غو
و hbo max
miss pepcik ، هل يمكنك إخبارنا بآخر
هذه الليلة في  فهمك
لمكان وجود أليكسيا نافالني
جيدًا
السيد كوبر ، يجب أن أكون صادقًا ،
ليس لدي أي فكرة عن مكان وجود ألكسندر
لا أحد يفعل ذلك حقًا ، فقد
اختفى اليوم ، لذا
ليس لدينا أي دليل على الإطلاق
حول مكان وجوده في الوقت الحالي ،
أبلغت وسائل الإعلام الحكومية الروسية عن
نقل البحرية إلى سجن شديد الحراسة
في منطقة فلاديمير في
البلد الذي تقول أنك لا تفعله  لا أعلم أين
هو ،
هل تعتقد أن الإبلاغ عن
ذلك لا أعتقد أنه من الدقة أه
أن أشير إليها على أنها وسائل إعلام حكومية روسية ،
فهذه
أنت تعرف نوعًا معينًا
من وسائل الإعلام التي
تبلغ عن ذلك  خطأ من
قبل ونعلم أنه في بعض الأحيان قد
يُطلب منهم فقط الإبلاغ عن
أي شيء تريد الدولة أن يؤمن به الناس ،
لذلك لا نعتمد على هذه
المعلومات حتى نسمع شيئًا
رسميًا حتى يتم
إخطارنا بأنه تم نقل البحرية وهذا هو
مستعمرة العقوبات الجديدة الخاصة به وهذا هو المكان الذي
يجب أن يتمكن محاموه من العثور عليه ، لذلك
لا نعتمد على هذه المعلومات ، هل
أنت أو محاميه قادرون على
أن أعني هل هناك أي شخص يمكنك
الاتصال به للحصول على معلومات أو يمكنني مساعدته  من الواضح أنك
لا تستطيع الاتصال
به بشكل جيد ، وهذا هو بيت القصيد من
الموقف هو أنه
كان يجب إخطار محاميه أو عائلته إذا
كان سيتم نقله إلى سجن مختلف أو
مستعمرة جنائية مختلفة ولكن
لم يتم إخطار أحد واليوم
كان الموقف هو أن محاميه ظهر
في مستعمرته العقابية الحالية
في باكروف ،
حيث تم احتجازه عند نقطة التفتيش
لبضع ساعات ثم
لم يظهر ، وهذا
كل ما نعرفه حرفيًا وهذا
ما هو
مخيف جدًا  والمزعج بشأن هذا
الموقف هو أنه منذ حوالي
16 ساعة و 18 ساعة في هذه المرحلة
، ليس لدينا طريقة لمعرفة مكانه ،
فمن الممكن أنه لا يزال في نفس
المستعمرة العقابية ولم يتم
إنتاجه من أجله.  المحامي
لا أعتقد أنه من الممكن أنه
لا يزال هناك ، فقد ذهب بالتأكيد إلى
مكان ما ، وعادة إذا كنا نعيش
إذا كانت الحكومة الروسية
قد اتبعت بالفعل القوانين التي
كتبوها بأنفسهم ، فسنبلغنا بذلك.  إذا تم نقله إلى
مكان مختلف ، فهناك إجراء
يكون قياسيًا جدًا وكان محاموه
سيحصلون عليه مثل
تأكيد مكتوب بأن
موكلك على وشك الانتقال من السجن
أ إلى السجن ب ويجب أن تكون كذلك  قادرين
على رؤيته في ذلك السجن من هذا
اليوم فصاعدًا ،
لكن الطريقة التي يفعلون بها ذلك مع
navalny هي نوع من المقاربة المختلفة جدًا
التي يجب عليهم التعامل معها ، فلا يوجد قانون يتم
تطبيقه عليه ، لذا في هذه الحالة
نحن محرومون من  أي
معلومات ونظل في هذا
الموقف غير المريح للغاية المتمثل في
معرفة أي شيء وعدم
القدرة على سؤال أي شخص بشكل أساسي ،
أعتقد أنه عندما
يخبروننا في النهاية ولكننا لا نعرف ما إذا كان
الأمر كذلك  غدا يقولون بعد
غد او بعد اسبوع او في
الشهر